we're getting a one-year time drum and a
musical number and I'm with our two most
musical girls on the show please tell me
this is including both of you sort of
but not including me but I have neither
of us are singing and I'm in the
sequence I mean one of the girls is seen
but it's not either of you not one of
the singers she's a singer
she is a singer you'll see it'll make
sense yeah woman illness um it was very
fun to shoot or shot like a music video
yeah yeah it was like it was a really
special day like took up a whole set
well what can you guys tease for that
one year jump ahead it's a two-hour
episode which is that's pretty cool I
think it's a lot of time to do a lot of
things but I mean that's the episode
where you get everybody the big answer
yahoo ideas which is very exciting and
there's a wedding or two or whatever
there's a couple the trails so the
trails a lot of the elephants pregnant
it's really cool to see how all the
girls deal with that and how else um
feels a bit and what its decisions are
and I've got a wedding Walker coming up
yeah I'm gonna see it miss aria walked
down the aisle
are we we better know we'll see Sherlock
on with it with that he is engage yeah
so
you